we have a very interesting situation
with regard to American drone policy and
usage you might remember that President
Obama caught a lot of flack for his
hawkish nests especially his willingness
to use drones and to allow collateral
damage in the use of those drones and in
fact the the constitutional fetishist
right along with many on the left would
regularly talk about how President Obama
is violating the Constitution using
drones in this scenario in that scenario
and there are actually right-wingers
that still today I know President Obama
is no longer president still today there
are there right wingers and trumpets
slamming Obama over his drone program
what has been less publicized is that
Donald Trump has drastically scaled up
use of drones during his just under two
months in office so far since Donald
Trump took office he has authorized 36
drone strikes that's more than one per
day at the time that that data was
measured overall President Obama's
average was one drone strike every 5.4
days and on Trump's resume of drone
usage we already have three drone
strikes in Yemen between January 20th
and 22nd that disastrous Navy SEAL raid
in Yemen on January 28th which is just
part of his military action not drone
specifically a drone strike in Pakistan
on March 1st 30 drone strikes in Yemen
on March 2nd and 3rd and another drone
strike in Yemen on March 6th and if you
look online in the pro-trump recesses of
the internet there have been memes
floating around about President Obama's
drone usage there have been critiques
floating around of President Obama's
drone usage meanwhile we see Donald
Trump tracking a 432 percent
drone use increase relative to President
Obama and this is number one concerning
because you see those who said hey
Obama's use was unconstitutional we care
about the Constitution now they're
silent but also because Trump campaigned
on being more apprehensive and reluctant
than other presidents to go to war and
to use deadly force he criticized Obama
and Hillary Clinton for their readiness
to use force abroad he claimed that he
always opposed the Iraq war wasn't
actually true he said he wouldn't have
intervened in Libya in 2011 the truth is
he went back and forth on that but it
doesn't matter that's what he claimed
and he said that in general he'd be more
careful than other presidents in terms
of engaging the military and spending
money on combat looks like he's going
back on that as well and the White House
is talking about in addition to this
drastic increase in drone usage sending
more ground troops to Syria loosening
the rules for engagement for air strikes
upping our assistance to Syrian rebels
all the Trump supporters said during the
election Trump is more sensible when it
comes to foreign policy they said Trump
is less militaristic Hillary would start
World War 3 even though Hillary Clinton
never campaigned on going to war with
Russia or anything close to it but we've
seen military engagements increased
drastically in the short time that Trump
has been president this yet again Pat is
more evidence that Donald Trump is gonna
end up being the neocon that his
campaign claimed that he would not be
it's kind of hard though it's of pin
down Donald Trump when it comes to
foreign policy so at some points he
would say that we need a non
interventionist approach kind of take on
the Rand Paul style as you mentioned and
then at other times he would say that we
need to bomb Isis to no end and take out
their families so pick and choose there
but when it comes to the drone program I
think Republicans were right to
criticize Obama on that it was probably
one of the worst parts of his legacy and
things like signature strikes and double
taps killed countless civilians the
problem is they have to be consistent so
if it was bad when Obama did it if
Trump's doing it at a rate four to five
times more so than it's that much worse
when he does it as well Trump promised
fewer wars but they were gonna be better
wars the best Wars absolutely tremendous
war as it seems that actually the
military action so far like Pat pointed
out is drastically exceeding that of
President Obama it's the party of it's
okay when we do it but otherwise impe
the traitor if it's a Democrat who does
it